I felt like the spirit of the VMAs was
like missing even there was no one there
that was just really kind of I felt like
that's the one night we can really go
for it it's really about celebrating
your videos and even Robin's video I
mean what could you expect like if you
look at our videos together you know
we're not going to come out and do the
hokey pokey yeah no no definitely not
[Music]
the most people who saw this music video
saw it in a viral clip of like
a goat screaming
which came out shortly after the video
and it's fine it's like I was like this
is really this is this is a viral video
this just happened I had no idea how
um but it ended up being one of the most
hilarious turn of events because it's
like it's like you just have no idea
where things are gonna come from out of
left field including like you know
screaming goats
[Music]
foreign
it's good
that's why people watch it so many times
they're in the studio this is at
halftime
and attempting to run to the board and
getting tangled up in the
monitor cable and there goes the Monitor
and there goes shaft I mean how sexy am
I really trying to be I've got damn
pigtails yeah I'm dressed as a bear and
like a onesie it was really the foam
finger that I think took things to the
next yeah everyone was talking about
that sponge finger yeah because you saw
that every time I look you're like
I think I was you had a rash I didn't
know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a very annoying guy on a flight with you
and uh which right which prank well you
know it happens a lot this one I'll
refresh your memory here
I do not know I do not know that guy
Tyson bro
Mike Tyson
Mike Tyson trying to give us some
shrooms
and this guy kept going and going and
going and so then you um did this are
you oh that's not me
that's not you that's not me yeah is
that him does that look like does that
look like look do that look like me no
it doesn't actually it's not me it
doesn't look anything right
it's not me
do people bother do people try they want
to get like oh I I smiled off to Mike
Tyson Hey listen um
I'm usually good at these things yeah
I've seen you be very very patient with
people
I guess guess it was his number yeah
how about this
[Laughter]
oh
the question is that Triple H
so I went
and all the girls just made it I see
them just move
I just let God take it from there
[Applause]
the red scene my man academics
[ __ ] said this this [ __ ] spread like
the rest here nothing I just saw God and
God said just you know prepare for
impact
[Applause]
it's true oh he's got herpes and he's
got it bad
I heard your doctor said it was the most
herpes he'd ever seen and of course
Bobby's reactions are so funny
he makes it all right basically it was
supposed to you know I was the groom and
I had two Brides right so you know the
groom and the bride are supposed to kiss
yeah and it was just meant to be a
playful kind of
um ironic comment on the bride and groom
kissing because I had two Brides I was
going to kiss both of my brothers and
all of the rehearsals we did it was very
you know mwah
right yeah and then more than one I know
yeah I know that but that's if if
Britney it looks like she's you know
kissing me in an aggressive manner it
was a surprise to me
I swear to God
yeah
we go got the signers
tremendous oh no I heard Stevenson
blowing you over huh oh my God
thank you you're holding a freaking
awesome I'm holding a freaking Oscar
I can't I've tripped so many times
because I'm walking going like licking
down at it like look amazing I tripped
up these stairs too so don't feel bad I
know you had your moment on stage oh my
God
it could be pretty much the most
embarrassing moment right
I think I think that's probably gonna go
go out there but I just heard that Hugh
Jackman helped me up I had no I didn't
know
no idea so that kind of like anybody
that makes fun of me I'm like yeah and
then I got touched by a Hugh Jackman
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
something weird happened at the Golden
Globe show and we have a clip of it I
wanted to play now Damien chazelle got
the director and writer of your film I
think it was for best screenplay he won
yes and well show that clip because uh
we'll examine it here
[Applause]
foreign
[Laughter]
now let's take a look at that again in
slow motion
what's occurring here as Damien goes
against his girlfriend Damien certainly
wants to hug not me
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
so uh your dad last night on stage with
Taylor Swift pretty cool uh what do you
think and she goes ah I thought your
walk was cheesy
[Laughter]
puts it all in perspective kids don't
care especially that age they don't care
yeah they're just dorks they don't care
it doesn't matter what you've done and
there's something else that brought a
lot of attention to this movie recently
Zach at the premiere yeah okay you want
to take me through what happened
uh I don't want to take you through it
but um do you want to just give me a
hint as to what happened you drop
something on the red carpet I did I did
uh and I never really had a pocket
checking policy prior to going onto the
red carpet before but now um now we
fully instated one
um
You Dropped a a condom yeah on the red
carpet which I think gives you it was
really it was really hard for you to say
no it wasn't actually no I think gives
you credit I mean you know better to be
safe than sorry right it's a great
message to add to the many messages in
the film exactly right you've got your
own production company what's next
what's next for you and that's a bad pun
by the way you're own production company
uh what what's next for you oh man like
literally left America I stopped doing
music all together I just took some time
I went to Japan just so I can get away
from Paparazzi all together and then in
November I moved to Rome and just like
lived there and then when I came back to
the States uh I moved to Hawaii and
lived there I was there for like six
months and just worked on music again
Taylor
I'm really happy for you I'm let you
finish but Beyonce had one of the best
videos of all time
one of the best videos of all time just
just for your whole world to completely
crash
off of a a moment of
sincerity or alcohol whatever whatever
it is to lose those don't usually go
together but yeah
you
sincerity party yeah